You need to put
all of those attributes together
and be able to make the deal happen.
So, as my boss once said,
"Look, at the end,
I give you a deal.
You'll make it happen at the end."
Ruby Chen, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Good morning to me,
good evening to you.
How are you?
I am doing fine.
So hopefully,
you know, from the name,
you were not envisioning
some sort of Chinese lady
from Singapore.
It is a bit misleading.
So, I get that a lot
when people see me
and expect to see a female
instead of maybe a Jewish kid
from New York City,
which I am actually from.
So, what is the story behind the Chen?
I haven't met many Jewish people
from Brooklyn with the last name Chen.
So, it depends who asks.
So, you know,
if it is people that are close to me,
so, it is actually a abbreviation
of a longer Jewish name.
But I did have the opportunity
when working at Amdocs,
which is a multinational company
on the M&A team,
we actually acquired a company
in France that the main customer
was China Mobile.
So, they needed to send somebody to China
to explain that we will continue
the commitments of the company
and everything is good.
So, who did they send?
They sent the Chinese guy.
Of course.
I was supposed to meet
some Chinese executives
from China Mobile
and when I walked in,
he was like looking,
"Wait a second,
where's that Chinese lady
that I was supposed to meet?"
So, I invented some family out in China.
It's a not that much of a known fact,
but during World War II, as you know,
the most of the borders were closed
for Jewish people
that wanted to exit Europe.
But actually one
of the countries that did have
their borders open was actually China.
So, there is actually Chinese Jewish
community that populated
during World War II.
So, I made up some Chinese family
and we ended up
being far distant cousins
and from there the deal went pretty well.
I think that's a phenomenal story.
Ruby, we have a lot of things
to talk about from running accelerators
when they weren't necessarily cool
all the way to doing
corporate venture capital,
which is also a little bit
of a new phenomena
that I've seen on the crazy uprising
in the past few years.
But you actually, again,
did that before it was cool.
So, I'm starting to see a pattern here
of identifying trends.
So, there's a lot to,
there's a lot for me to learn here.
Can you tell me
a little bit about your journey?
How do you get to being
a director at these fantastic companies
and then being on the wave
of these great trends?
Well, to the young audience here,
I would have like to say
that there was a plan
and a scheme behind it,
but it kind of happens by accident.
Right.
More often than not.
So, in my personal case,
coming from New York City
and being native US speaker,
so, being here in Israel,
that was kind of like
an unfair competitive advantage.
So, that's how I got into
the high tech business to begin with.
It started by joining a
semi governmental entity here in Israel
that provided subsidized
economic services to startups.
Meaning, lining the business plans
and talking about marketing plans.
So, you know, having that
native English back then
kind of helped me get into that domain
and I was working in a entity
that had a lot of startups
that we supported.
And there I got to know a little bit
of the ecosystem
and, you know, talking to people
and getting to understand that,
and that's how I got into my first gig,
which was the venture capital firm
in Israel called Stage One Ventures.
It was a $35 million fund.
The main LPs was Bezeq,
which is the Israeli quad-play
sort of telecommunication plan.
I didn't realize that they
have an arm into venture capitals.
This is so interesting.
Hey, dude, I'm a bit ancient,
so, I'm talking about 20 years ago.
So, you don't take everything
in perspective but,
it was something that Bezeq
did at the past.
And the idea of the fund,
because it was a relatively small fund,
was to ask itself, okay,
how do I maximize
the capital commitment that I have.
And at that time,
Israel had and still does
a program of technology incubators,
which at the time was owned
and managed by the state of Israel.
And they came to the conclusion,
the state of Israel,
that managing an incubator
isn't probably one
of the core competencies of a state
and that's why
they wanted to privatize it.
Now, when are we talking about?
At what year?
Probably about 2001, 2002.
Wow. That's unbelievable.
So, we're talking about 20 years ago.
Right.
Time flies when you're having fun, man.
And so, the idea was to
they use those people
that did not know about this program.
It's a pretty innovative program
that the state of Israel created
in the mid 90s
when there was that large influx
of Russian immigrants.
And instead of just
having these people do,
you know, low level work
because they did not know the language,
the state wanted to utilize these people
and be able to utilize
the technology capabilities
that they have.
So, they created this program
that basically subsidized
the first two years of R&D development
that the state of Israel takes most
of the risk associated with that.
So, as a private investor you put in
one dollar and the state gives you
four dollars back
up to a budget of about $600,000.
Which is good for about
a year and a half.
So, what the evolution
of the program was,
is that you have
this large influx of Russians,
but it was also open
to other types of entrepreneurs as well,
not only Russian immigrants.
But as I described previously,
the state after
a couple of years understood
it would be better to move
into private hands.
Now, why is that?
Tell me a little bit
about this transition?
Because it's a really interesting
piece of the history, you know.
Today, there must be,
dozens, if not hundreds of incubators
and accelerators just in Israel.
Right?
And just in Tel Aviv,
not even counting those in Jerusalem
and the different areas,
what was that process like
for the Israeli state,
the government, to run
one of the first incubators
to start that trend
and then make that rational decision
of moving it to private hands?
Yeah. So, I think the state of Israel
was able to identify pretty amazingly,
a market inefficiency.
And throughout the years of the program,
even today, the way that
the chief innovation officer
of the state of Israel looks at it
is to identify
those market inefficiencies
that evolve over the years.
So, at the beginning saying, okay,
look, this early stage of investments,
there's a gap here.
So, there are VCs that do investments
but they do not want
to take that high level of risk.
So, how do I identify or create
such a program that can
deal with that inefficiency.
And over the years, it has changed.
So, many years ago,
the state of Israel identified
that biotech, is has been on the sub.
So, they created a program specifically
for biotech companies.
And being always on top of things,
trying to understand them,
over the years as being the CEO
of a technology incubator,
also in the city of Tel Aviv,
compared to maybe
an incubator in the north of Israel
or the south,
you can guess I was on speed dial
of many of the different delegations
that were visiting here in Israel
that try to understand
and duplicate this program.
And actually, we had the opportunity
and many times actually
to visit different countries,
Europe, Asia,
anything in between saying, look,
we want to try to duplicate
this for our ecosystem.
But the question is,
which is the long conversation
that we don't have time
to go into today,
is what is the special ingredients
that enabled the Israeli ecosystem
to flourish and to be what it is today,
the startup nation?
So, that's a long conversation.
But you know, anyone that wants
to hear more about that,
we can go into that into detail, so.
The technology incubator thing
at the beginning,
we were able to utilize Bezeq
and play with the Bezeq Labs,
which means, you know,
telecommunications, cybersecurity,
before that was cool,
as well as different types of technologies.
Again, we're talking about 20 years ago.
Right?
Unbelievable.
15 to 18 years ago, yeah.
So, the best things
that we had actually
was a company we put in $600,000,
a company in the telecommunication
authentication space
that was called Traffix Systems
that was acquired by F5
for $130 million a few years after.
So, you do the math yourself
you understand, you know, from the
$30 million dollar fund
that sounds like a nice return
on an investment.
100%.
So, I did that for about four years.
And then being able to
have experience of playing
or being into action
with a large corporate like Bezeq
to identify new investments
and utilize that, I was recruited by a
New York Stock Exchange,
traded Israeli company
called Amdocs, A-M-D-O-C-S,
which is a pretty big company
in Israeli standards.
Its market cap is about
$12 billion today.
They sell about five billion annually.
So, what they do
is they provide software solutions
for telecommunication
and media companies.
So, think about the billing
of your mobile phone
from AT&T at the end of the month,
that is being generated
from a Amdocs billing system.
When you call into a call center
of a Verizon,
that also the back end,
the software is a Amdocs system
more often than not.
And if you think about
the network itself,
you know, the 3G,4G, 5G,
all that software
that manages the different networks
is also managed by an Amdocs system.
So, Amdocs at the time
also had a open innovation program.
And this is again talking 2007, 2008
and they had a small team
that was supposed to interact
with the Israeli ecosystem
and one program was to take
a startup technology,
combine it with a Amdocs solution,
create a new offering
and then sell it to an AT&T,
or to Verizon or T-Mobile.
They had another small team
that also had the action item
of when having delegations
such as AT&T
or Vodafone visit as to match
between the Israelis startups to
the requirements
of the telecommunications company,
working very closely
with the sales teams
of the Amdocs to be able
to identify missing gaps
and to understand
what the requirements are.
So, they were missing
that small program
to get some skin in the game.
So, saying, look,
if we're helping these startups
develop these new technologies,
products based on requirements
and also selling it to them,
why not also the venture program.
Right.
That makes perfect sense.
That is what's called the CVC,
which is a Corporate
Venture Capital program.
So, I was given the task,
okay, go figure it out
and go create something.
So today, when you think about CVCs,
there are hundreds,
if not thousands of programs like that
within the Fortune 1000,
I think maybe 80% of them
have some sort of program like that.
But go back about 12 years ago,
not that common.
So, at the time,
there wasn't too many people to
study and to try to duplicate
what can be done.
So in Israel, we had Cisco,
which had a venture program.
We had Motorola,
which also one of the first ones.
IBM, which have been here also
for many years.
But there weren't too many.
So, how do you put together
a investment charter.
Meaning, okay, how do you invest
and what do you invest,
who's the investment committee.
Right.
So, typically you need
to have a CFO
because she signs the check
at the end of the day.
But you have someone from product,
you have somebody from sales,
do you create the fund
with a dedicated capital
that is dedicated to investments,
or does it come out
of the balance sheet,
so, all of these questions, you know,
were kind of open
with me given the task
to go figure it out
and come up with something.
I would like to share one antidot,
of that process.
The CEO of Amdocs at the time,
his name was Dov Baharav,
he of course, I wanted him
on the investment committee.
You always want the CEO
But actually, he said something
that had a lot of sense.
And you know, over the years,
i even believe it even more
in what he had to say, he said,
"Look, if I'm on the investment committee,
everybody else will wait
to listen what I have to say,
and then make their decision.
It would be better
for you not to have me
on the investment committee
and then you could have
that open discussion
that you're looking for,
refine those hidden gems
that might not come on
to all later
because it's not currently
in high priority."
But the intention of the program
was indeed to find
those types of companies
that are up and coming
that maybe at a corporate culture
you might miss.
So, I started doing that.
I made a lot of investments
in the mobility space.
The more famous ones is
in the mobile advertising space,
a company called  Amobee,
which was acquired by SingTel
for $340 million.
We invested in another company in Israel,
Trivnet mobile payment,
again, I'm talking about 2008, 2009,
which was sold to Gemalto
the same manufacturer.
We also had a company called Pontis
that actually justified
the model of the CVC,
meaning you invest in a company sometimes
because you're not prepared
to do the M&A yet.
So, you say, you know what,
let me put some cash in.
I get some ability
to influence the company.
And also, if there is an acquisition
on the table
then I am able to manage that
maybe more quickly
and be able to act on that.
So, this company called Pontis,
which we invested in 2008,
was eventually acquired by Amdocs,
which kind of justifies the model
of why to do a series [--].
So, what it sounds to me is that
the difference with CVC is that,
CVC, it is very similar to venture capital
in the sense that you're, you know,
you're buying equity
into another business,
say, for various incentives,
but you're introducing
another layer of complexity
both because of the different interests
that could arise.
So, when a regular VC invests,
it's primarily for the financial returns.
But when you're introducing
a corporate venture capital fund,
there's all sorts of incentives.
One of those, for example,
is to be able to influence
the decision making of a company
which could potentially
at some point merge into yours
and you want to be able
to either influence their technology,
their roadmap,
their financials, their other customers.
So, it sounds like
it's very complicated.
And I think it's really inspiring
that you got to be there
and be really a pioneer.
From what it sounds like,
in a world where today
like you're mentioning,
almost every Fortune 1000 company
has a venture capital arm.
Yeah. And it has evolved over the years.
And this also could be
a 101 session of a CVC.
So, over the years
they have been developed
different flavors of types of CVCs.
So, just going flash forward with myself,
moving from Amdocs
to another corporate called, Nice,
which is traded on the Nasdaq,
also market cap is about
12 billion today.
It's a enterprise software company
that captures [--] data sets,
normalizes them and finds insights.
So, it's a data analytics company
where the main data source
that they started was voice.
So, again, think about large B2C
organizations, banks,
Telcos, media companies,
so, when you call
into one of those entities,
you have that annoying message
at the beginning that says
this call is now being recorded
for compliance.
So, eight out of 10 times
in North America,
that would be a Nice system.
And by capturing that actual data
and being able to do speech to text
text analytics, emotion detection,
next best action
for the call agent itself,
there's a lot of value
that is hidden in that.
So, at that entity as well,
I was at the club dev team
doing ventures and M&As.
And the last two years,
I actually established
and led the Hyundai,
a motor company venture,
activities here in Tel Aviv.
So, I've been doing CVCs for 12 years.
So, there's a lot to be said
and to be discussed about
if you are a young guy
that wants to get into that space,
I could be glad you know,
give me a call, to look me up.
I'll be glad to share
some of the insights,
and some of the things I've gone through.
Wonderful. Ruby,
it sounds like there's more hours
and more of content
that we could talk about
that would be fascinating,
whether it's the Israeli ecosystem
and watching it from the roots of it,
you know, 20 years ago
with Bezeq, and then moving on
to CVCs and seeing where that trend
is going today,
to talking about mobility
and enterprise software,
there's endless more
that we could discuss.
But unfortunately,
we do have only 20 minutes.
So, I have to ask you
the last and most important question,
which is three words
that you would use
to describe yourself.
Yeah, that's a nice question to ask.
I would start with curious.,
So starting from telecom
and then doing enterprise software
and then auto tech.
So, I guess I'm just waiting for
that corporate that's
in the biotech space.
So, I could feel that I've
you know, checked all the boxes.
A deal maker.
Yeah.
So, one of my previous boss said
and this is again,
maybe something to the younger audience,
"How do you become
the best deal maker?"
So, as my boss once said to me
in a larger audience,
"It's not because I'm the guy
that knows how to build
the best excel
for the financial model.
That's not being
the best technology guy
that knows how to understand
and understand the technology benefit.
It's not the HR side
which is also highly appreciated
at the end."
Because it's a people thing
if you acquire a company,
you invest in a company,
so, people business.
Right.
But you need to put
all of those attributes together
and be able to make the deal happen.
So, as my boss once said,
"Look, at the end,
I give you a deal.
You'll make it happen at the end."
And I think, you know,
that's a very nice compliment I have
and also for those young people
to think about that as well.
So, last but not least,
I think connected.
So, being part of this ecosystem,
not only the Israeli ecosystem,
but the corporate venture capital
ecosystem for the last 20 years,
you get to know people
and at the end,
you know, you have that
ability to be familiar with people
over the years.
And then when you do come to them
and come with ideas
and want to collaborate, you know,
based on the reputation
that you're able to build for yourself
over the years,
that is something that's very hard
to establish
and it's like easy to lose.
So, you need to be very
diligent on those types of approaches
and who do you approach and when.
So, being that connector,
I think also something
that is highly important
to think about as well.
And now we have
the Dubai ecosystem as well
that Michael, you just came back
from that you could say
a word or two about building bridges
and being a guy
that could connect between the dots
is something that
is a skill set that I think
Israelis acquired today.
And I think that one of the,
one of the most, like you mentioned,
I just literally 12 hours ago
I got back from Dubai.
This will be shared
with our audience in a few weeks.
But just got off the flight recently.
And I think one of the things
that fascinated me most
was understanding cultural differences
and really opening ourselves up
to a whole new world
where business is important.
But connections,
and human to human connections
and trust is at the forefront
of these business endeavors.
And I think that is something
that I was very inspired by this week.
I got so used to the
Western way of doing business
and talking to each other
and forming relationships.
It's very different over there.
And I'm just starting to learn
how to do it.
And I can't,
and I'm 100% sure that
Dubai and that part of the world
is going to be a major part
of my professional life
and probably that of many people
in Israel and the US.
So, I think that we need to start
from the culture.
But I definitely take to heart
what the answers from this talk.
And Ruby, I really want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
It was really, really wonderful.
Thank you for the inspiration.
And I have a feeling
we're going to have
to do a few more episodes
to really capture some of those
other insights
that you were talking about.
Yeah, will be glad to share my insights
so many of the young guys
out there are listening
all ladies, please,
feel free to reach out.
Will be glad to share.
Wonderful.
Thank you very much, Ruby.
Take care.